[MUSIC PLAYING]
ZAK STONE: Hello, everyone, and
welcome to effective machine
learning with Cloud TPUs.
I'm delighted to
see all of you here.
And I'd like to send a
special welcome to everyone
on the livestream or
anyone who's watching
this as a recording later.
I'm Zak Stone.
I'm the product manager for
TensorFlow and Cloud TPUs
on the Google Brain Team.
And this talk is
about supercomputers
for machine learning that are
built around Google's custom
chips called Tensor
Processing Units, or TPUs.
We've had three generations
of Tensor Processing Units,
including the one on
the bottom that Sundar
announced in his keynote
earlier this morning.
But before I get into
the details here,
I just want to set
the stage for a moment
and share a little bit of
context about why this matters.
There's been a tremendous amount
of machine learning progress
over the past several
years, as you've already
heard earlier today.
If you look at the number
of research publications
on Archive, which is an open
site for sharing papers,
the number of papers
published is growing faster
than Moore's law.
And we're up to something
like 50 new machine
learning papers every day.
This is a tremendous
rate of innovation.
A lot of it's happening in
the open, which is fantastic.
And it's driving a lot
of new applications
and real progress across
a wide range of fields.
As you can see here in just
one domain, computer vision,
there's been a
tremendous increase
in accuracy on this
ImageNet benchmark challenge
just over the past
few years, rising
from the original breakthrough
results with AlexNet,
all the way to some of the more
recent machine learning models.
But these accuracy
trends come at a cost
that I'll tell you
about in a minute.
First, I want to
help you understand
what those sort of
applications are about.
You've heard a little bit
about diabetic retinopathy,
and also these new
signals of heart health
that you can get in a
completely passive way
just by taking a picture
of the back of the eye.
This is the kind of
real-world application
that's going to help
improve people's lives
that's only possible because of
these cutting-edge, accurate,
powerful models in
machine learning.
You've also probably heard
about tracking illegal logging
in the rain forest by putting
recycled cell phones in trees
that can listen for sounds of
chainsaws or other activities
and help people protect rain
forests in the central Amazon.
Now one thing that's
really changed,
even since I was
in graduate school,
is this unification across many
different application domains.
Before, it might have been that
the folks in computer vision
had one set of techniques, the
folks in speech recognition
had a different
set of techniques,
and the folks doing
machine translation
were doing yet a third
set of techniques
to go from one
language to another.
But what we've been seeing
over the past few years
is this consolidation,
especially in deep learning
around these neural
networks that
have similar components, even if
the details of their structure
are different.
And these neural networks are
now achieving state-of-the-art
results across all
these different tasks.
Often these results
are at accuracies
that we don't know how
to achieve any other way.
So now as I mentioned
earlier, this
has come at a bit
of a cost, which
is as these models
get more accurate,
they tend to be larger--
trained on larger datasets--
and that means that you
need more computation,
both to train the
model on the dataset
and then eventually to run it.
What I'm showing here is this
plot of these image recognition
models on ImageNet, this
time ranked with accuracy
on the vertical axis and then
the number of multiply adds--
which is sort of a rough
metric of computational costs
on the horizontal axis.
And as you can see, as you
get to these higher and higher
accuracies, you're actually
requiring larger and larger
amounts of computation.
So the solution to this
problem, we believe,
is specialized hardware
for machine learning.
And that's what's
really driven us
to develop these multiple
generations of Tensor
Processing Units, or TPUs.
Our first TPUs have been in
our data center since 2015.
And you've interacted with these
every time you've run a search.
They're reranking the
last several hundred links
to choose the 10 that
they're showing you.
They've been a central
part of Google Photos,
and speech recognition,
and many of Google's
large-scale applications
that you use every day.
Last year, we revealed
our second generation
Tensor Processing Units,
which are now in public beta.
Anyone can sign up.
Any GCP project can
start a cloud TPU.
And you can follow the link
g.co/cloudtpu to learn more.
These TPUs aren't just
for training an inference
on a single system, though.
They're really designed
to be connected together
into these large-scale
supercomputers
that we call TPU pods.
And later this year,
TPU pods are coming
to cloud as Cloud TPU pods.
Here's a full pod of the second
generation TPUs on the screen
right now.
Finally, this morning, you're
getting the first glimpse
of our third generation
TPUs, assembled
into an even larger
TPU pod that delivers
more than 100
petaflops of compute
for a single machine
learning problem.
So I just want to
emphasize that we
are committed to making
relentless progress
in this domain.
This affects all
of our products.
It improves the lives
of all of our users.
And through the cloud, we're
bringing these platforms
to you, so you can train
machine learning models
and run them faster and more
cost-effectively than ever
before.
Just a few notes on performance.
You can see TPU v1 with 92
teraops only doing inference.
Then going to the Cloud
TPU, which is 180 teraflops.
Suddenly, you have
floating point.
It's a lot easier to work with.
You don't have to worry
about quantization.
And those are connected
together into these systems
that, as I mentioned before,
are up to 11.5 petaflops,
and do training and inference,
either on a single problem
or you can slice them
into smaller pieces
to do many different
problems at once.
Just a year later
now, we're making
this leap from about 11.5
petaflops to more than 100.
That's more than 8x the
performance of a TPU v2
pod in this new v3 system.
And that's a combination
of an entirely new chip
wired together into an
even larger-scale system.
So I hope the reason
that you're all here
is because you're interested
in expanding the AI frontier.
That's what really
motivates us when
we're developing these
platforms and building
applications on top of them.
Now, I'd really like
to focus on what
you can do right now with the
Cloud TPUs that are available
today.
And that really starts
with performance.
A lot of these machine
learning models
can take days or weeks to train.
It hasn't been uncommon
in the past for it
to cost thousands
of dollars just
to do one training run of
these machine learning models.
And we're really interested
in bringing down those costs
and making machine learning
acceleration much more widely
available.
But when we're talking
about performance,
it's important to be very
specific about what we mean,
because it's quite subtle
sometimes to compare
one system to another.
First of all, in all
of our measurements,
we try to focus on real-world
data, time to accuracy,
and cost.
So let me tell you what I mean.
When you're training a
machine learning model
and you're processing
millions of images,
it's convenient to look at how
many samples a second you're
processing as a
measure of performance.
But those samples
per second numbers
don't matter unless
you ultimately
get where you need to go, reach
the correct final accuracy.
And so what we're
really looking to do
is, yes, measure how fast the
wheels are spinning on the car,
but also make sure that the car
gets to the right destination
and crosses the finish line.
So it's very important
whenever you're
considering building, buying,
renting a machine learning
system, to make sure that you're
asking about not only steps
per second or
samples per second,
but also the training
accuracy and the total time
to accomplish the task that
you really have in mind.
We've also put in
a lot of energy
to try and make sure
that all these ML
benchmarks that
we talk about are
reproducible via open source.
So almost all of the numbers
that I'm about to show you,
either you can reproduce today
by going to g.co/cloudtpu
and renting a Cloud TPU or
they'll be open source soon,
and so you'll be able to
reproduce them on your own.
You don't just have to
take my word for it.
Now, Stanford recently hosted
a competition called DAWNBench.
I've got a screenshot
of the website here.
And DAWNBench is the first
public benchmark challenge
that we've seen really measure
performance and accuracy
together, which we
think was great.
There was active participation
from many different companies,
and individuals,
and research groups.
And I'm happy to announce
that Cloud TPUs and TPU
pods did very well across
several of the categories.
So in the ImageNet
Training Cost competition,
we had the number
one DAWNBench entry
with a model called
AmoebaNet-D. Now
this is a really interesting
fusion of some of the work
that we've been
doing in research
with these new
hardware platforms,
because AmoebaNet was an
architecture that was actually
evolved from scratch on TPUs.
And then that model, not only
if you train it longer can get
to state-of-the-art
accuracy on ImageNet,
but it can hit the target that
DAWNBench set of 93% in just
7.5 hours for under $50.
This really makes this kind of
state-of-the-art performance
accessible to a much wider
audience than it's ever been
before.
Now, another model that you may
have heard of that's frequently
benchmarked is ResNet-50.
And so I just wanted to show a
quick case study of ResNet-50
running with
TensorFlow 1.8, which
is our most recent version.
We also submitted
this to DAWNBench,
and it also reaches this
accuracy of 93%, which is not--
this is top 5 accuracy-- that's
not easy to do with ResNet.
That it's easy to fall
just a little bit short.
And you have to be very careful
throughout the implementation
to achieve that high
accuracy while maintaining
this incredible
performance of more
than 3,250 images per second.
Now this took almost nine
hours to train for $59.
But if you want
to go faster, part
of the reason that we design
these systems to be connected
together is just by changing
the batch size of the model--
no code changes, no
complicated thinking
about distributed systems--
we can run the same thing on
half of one of these TPU pods
to hit the same level of
accuracy in just 30 minutes.
So that's nine hours
down to 30 minutes.
And these are the
pods that are coming
to cloud later this year.
So you'll be able to run
results like this on your own
or train on other models with
other datasets of your own.
And if you eliminate the
checkpoint overhead, which
DAWNBench didn't actually
require us to measure,
that's actually just 24 minutes.
So what I'd like
to mention, though,
is the field is
moving extremely fast.
So just as an example,
the third place entry
for training costs
on DAWNBench was
from a nonprofit
organization called fast.ai.
And that actually
came in at $72,
but it included some
really interesting ideas
that weren't well-known.
One was this progressive
scaling up of training images
that enabled the model to move
even faster in the earlier
phases of training, when it's
just starting to figure out
how to complete the task.
And they also used a much
more aggressive learning rate
schedule that hadn't
been widely used.
The nice thing about Cloud
TPU is it was easy for us
to make these open changes
in our own model on Cloud TPU
and unofficially
rerun the experiment.
And these two simple changes
take our ResNet-50 training
cost from $59 down to just $25
with today's on-demand pricing
that you can get
on Google Cloud.
So there's an open source
reference implementation
available.
We've built this into our
bfloat16 version of ResNet-50.
And we'll have more to
say about this soon.
But kudos to fast.ai for the
great algorithmic improvements.
And I'm just delighted as a
researcher and practitioner,
and now product manager,
that so much of this progress
is widely shared.
So you might be
wondering, well, what's
the next benchmark challenge?
DAWNBench finished recently.
Where do we go next to compare
these very different systems
of different sizes and scales
and even different model
architectures
against one another
if we need to make a decision
about what to do when
you want to accomplish a goal?
Well, one new challenge
that's been released recently
is MLPerf.
You can learn more
about it at mlperf.org.
There are a bunch of researchers
from different top universities
and also many companies
coming together
to try and define a new next
generation benchmark that's
even more challenging
than DAWNBench
and covers many more
problem domains.
The first deadline is
going to be in July.
This group is open
to new collaborators,
and also planning to iterate on
the definition of the benchmark
to make sure that
it really tracks
where the field is going.
So I think this is going
to be really exciting later
this year.
And I encourage you to
participate and check it out.
And as I've mentioned
before, I just
want to provide a little bit
more information about what
you can do today with Cloud
TPUs if you want to experience
this kind of performance.
We've got the set
of reference models.
I'll say more about
them in a minute,
but they're right there on
github.com/tensorflow/tpu.
And we've also got great
documentation on the Cloud TPU
website with the link below.
But you don't have to remember
the big links at the top,
just g.co/cloudtpu will take
you where you need to go.
So now I'd like to give
you a sense of what
it's like hands-on to
use these Cloud TPUs.
First of all, one
thing that's a little
different than
other accelerators
is that they're
network-attached.
So what that means is you
can choose a virtual machine
of any size or shape.
You can attach other
accelerators to it if you want.
It can be large.
But you would generally
start with a very tiny VM,
because this is really playing
just a coordinating role.
As few as four cores
are often enough,
because all the real
computational work
is happening on the Cloud TPU.
The nice thing
about this setup is
that Cloud TPU can
be a single device
or it can be a slice
of one of those pods.
You don't have to
worry about it.
All that's handled for you.
Furthermore, you
don't have to worry
about messing with drivers.
You can just use these machine
images that we provide.
You program these Cloud
TPUs with TensorFlow.
Now, TensorFlow is the most
popular open source framework
for machine learning, one of
the top projects on GitHub,
and it's just taken off since
it was open sourced in November
of 2015.
We're now up to something
like 13 million downloads all
around the world.
TensorFlow supports
many different kinds
of machine learning and has
many different components.
When you're programming
Cloud TPUs today,
you'll focus on layers,
estimators, the tf.data fast
input pipelines,
and then your code
will be transformed behind
the scenes by the XLA compiler
to talk to the TPU.
So estimators and
layers really provide
these flexible high-level
deep learning abstractions
for TensorFlow that let
you map a wide variety
of different models to TPUs.
Here's just a quick
code sample of
a convolutional neural network.
And this is how you would write
it with layers and estimators
with some code elided.
What you can see
here is that you just
have to make some minimal
changes to map this over
to the TPU--
changes in the optimizer
and the estimator.
And we're working over time
to make these changes smaller
and smaller, so that it'll
be really convenient for you
to take TensorFlow code
that runs on CPUs or GPUs,
run it on TPUs, move back and
forth wherever you need to take
your code and train or run.
One important bit
of advice, though,
that I'd like to just
emphasize over and over--
high-performance computing
is hard on any platform,
and these accelerators are so
fast that you need to really
put in a lot of energy to make
sure that the whole system is
balanced and that
every part of it
is performing as well
as it possibly can.
We've done a tremendous
amount of this work for you
with these reference models
that I'm about to show you,
that we've got open
source on GitHub.
For example, here are
four different categories
of very different applications
that are either supported today
or are about to be open
sourced for Cloud TPU.
Over in the image
recognition column,
which is maybe best known, we've
got AmoebaNet and ResNet-50--
also bigger versions of it--
Inception v2, v3, v4.
But we can also do object
detection with RetinaNet,
which is another one of these
recent state-of-the-art models.
And I'll say more
about that in a minute.
Also if you're interested in
training a machine learning
model and then deploying
it at the edge on a phone,
or a robot, or a drone, or in
a vehicle, or somewhere else,
you might want to train a
smaller model with something
like MobileNet or SqueezeNet.
And Cloud TPUs
support those as well.
But we're not limited to just
image recognition or object
detection.
TPUs can also do machine
translation and language
modeling, sentiment
analysis, question answering,
all with this state-of-the-art
model architecture called
Transformer that's very
powerful and flexible.
Turns out a version
of Transformer
can also perform fantastic
speech recognition.
And we've just recently
open sourced an example
of speech recognition
training on Cloud TPUs
as part of the
Tensor2Tensor framework.
I'll tell you more
about that in a minute.
And finally, for those of you
who are researchers out there
and are at the cutting edge
where you're generating images
from scratch, over in the
image generation category,
we've got the Image
Transformer and also DCGAN.
So we've really got a huge range
of applications that are not
only possible to make
work on the Cloud TPU,
but they're working today
with open source code
that you can just download.
It's a really easy
way to get started.
So for those of you who aren't
as familiar with this domain,
image classification is often
taking these small images,
like this one, and mapping
that to a category like "lion."
Whereas object detection
is taking a larger images
and looking for many
different objects
in many different
places in the image.
The cool thing about our
RetinaNet implementation
is it lets you process
quite large images--
896 by 896-- trains to a
very interesting accuracy
on the COCO dataset--
37 average precision in
just six hours for $40.
Machine translation training on
the WMT dataset gets to a BLEU
score of 28.6, which is very
close to the state-of-the-art,
again, in just
6.2 hours for $41.
And these results are
changing all the time
as we continue to optimize the
platform, the implementations,
and new research comes
out, much of which
at Google is conducted
on these TPUs.
Now language modeling--
you're trying
to predict the next word.
This is an important
component of applications
like Smart Reply.
And again, you can take the
language modeling-- the LM1B--
the one billion word dataset--
and train to a state-of-the-art
perplexity of 28 in 74 hours
for under $500.
And I've mentioned
Tensor2Tensor again below.
That's this open source project
built on top of TensorFlow
that has some of the latest
and greatest results for all
of these
sequence-to-sequence models.
For speech
recognition, we've got
this model called ASR
Transformer, which
is training on LibriSpeech,
again, to a really
interesting word error rate.
This is a fantastic way if you
have a large labeled speech
dataset to just train your own
near state-of-the-art speech
recognition model from scratch
in whatever language or accent
you care about.
And you can get to a reasonable
accuracy for under $100.
Finally, question
answering here with QANet.
This is just the
fast version that we
used to win the
Question Answering
Competition for DAWNBench, but
there's a Stanford question
and answer dataset that
takes a big chunk of text
and then presents a question
about some fact that you can
infer from reading the text.
So this machine learning
model is actually
looking at this whole
paragraph of unstructured text,
reading the question, and
then pinpointing the answer.
It's really impressive.
It's really different
from image recognition.
And all this is possible on
this flexible, new, powerful
platform for machine learning.
Oh, I forgot I was going to
tell you a little bit more
about image generation.
So the metric here is
actually bits per dimension,
and lower is better.
State-of-the-art is
around 2.92 right now,
but under 3 is really good.
And you can get under
3 on this metric
in 30 hours for under $200.
If you're interested
in exploring this
state-of-the-art, cutting-edge
image generation examples,
all those images on the right
were generated from scratch.
Just dreaming on the
basis of a training
set using this image
transformer model.
So again, why start
with a reference model
instead of just
opening a code editor
and starting from scratch?
Well, these reference
models are high performance,
they're open source,
they're cutting-edge,
often collecting
input from researchers
all across Alphabet.
We continuously test them
for performance and accuracy,
which means that you
don't have to worry
that some subtle
change in TensorFlow
or some other part of the
stack might reduce the accuracy
without you realizing it.
You can get up and
running really quickly,
and then modify as needed
because you have the code.
It's yours on your
infrastructure.
And you can train and
run on your own data.
But you're perfectly welcome
to do it the hard way.
We have lots of detailed
technical advice
in our troubleshooting guide.
And you know, I'm not kidding
that high-performance computing
is hard and any part of the
system can become a bottleneck,
but we totally encourage you
to take the high-level layers
and estimators APIs
and build new models
and let us know
what works for you.
Just to give you a little
bit of a sense of what
makes high-performance
computing so tricky,
if you're training
with slower hardware,
you might find that you
can overlap your input
preprocessing with
your training time,
and so your accelerators
are always saturated.
But when the accelerators
get a lot faster,
what you find all of a
sudden is that you're
bottlenecked on the
input processing
and your accelerators
are sitting idle.
And so fortunately, we've
provided a bunch of tools that
are connected into TensorBoard--
which is this great
visualization framework
associated with TensorFlow--
to help you debug
your performance,
understand what's going on.
Here, I'm showing the steps
per second and the loss.
But we actually have this
very detailed profiler
that lets you go in and get
op-by-op statistics on what's
going on in your model.
And we even have
high-level recommendations.
I don't know if you
can read the red text,
but it's telling
you in this case,
your model is not
input-bound, so you
should spend more time
on optimizing the step
performance.
In other cases, it'll tell
you you're blocked on input.
Don't bother improving
the speed of your model.
You need a faster
input pipeline.
And that's where
tf.data can help.
So we're really doing
our best to present
these tools for experts and all
this documentation for experts,
but also to make it
really easy to get started
with these reference models
across this huge range
of applications.
Now, those of you who are
used to training and running
machine learning models
under your desk, you
might wonder, well, why
should I jump to the cloud?
That seems like a
different platform.
How do I think about that?
The nice thing about
training in the cloud
is that you get access to all
this top-notch infrastructure
where you can mix and match the
different components you need,
like those custom VM shapes I
was telling you about earlier.
You can scale up
and down quickly.
You don't need to
order hardware,
maybe build a machine yourself,
wait for months sometimes
for hardware to arrive.
You can just sign on today and
scale up to hundreds of TPUs
if you wish.
There's great security all
throughout Google Cloud.
Google is state-of-the-art
in security across the entire
platform for enterprises that
want cutting-edge machine
learning hardware.
And you're really able to
reduce your capital expenditure.
With this on-demand
pricing, you're just
paying only for what you use.
You can train one of
these models for $50,
and then turn the cloud TPU off,
and you're not paying for it
anymore, which is great.
So just a few words from two of
our customers for Cloud TPUs.
Two Sigma is a financial firm.
And Lyft, this is their
self-driving vehicle team.
Both of them have
had great experiences
using Cloud TPUs to focus
on building the models
instead of worrying about
these massive distributed
clusters of other
hardware, and taking
these models that used to
train for days in some cases,
down to hours.
And with these larger
and larger pods,
we're really trying to
drive that to minutes.
So let's go under the hood
and talk in a little bit
more detail about what's going
on in the current generation
of Cloud TPU.
So first of all, the Cloud
TPU actually includes a host
with this accelerator,
all behind the scenes,
connected via PCI.
Each Cloud TPU device has these
four chips under the heat sinks
here.
And I'm going to zoom
in on one of them.
If you look at the
Cloud TPU chip layout,
you'll see that it's broken
down into two cores that
look like this.
Now, these cores
are really built
around this systolic array,
which is an old idea,
but it's newly relevant
in this age of machine
learning when so many
of the computations
really look like gigantic
matrix multiplies.
But we've also got a vector
unit and a scalar unit.
And in this case,
it was 8 gigabytes
of high-bandwidth
memory per core.
And then there are
two cores per chip.
The new TPU v3 actually
doubles the memory
per chip, which is going to let
you train even larger and more
capable models.
Focusing in on this matrix
unit, this is a systolic array.
One thing that's really
interesting about it
is that we're actually
doing the multiplies
with a new floating point
format that's called bfloat16.
I'll say more about
that in a minute,
but it really gives us
this great performance
for machine learning without
a meaningful cost in accuracy.
We're still accumulating
in float32, though.
So most of you are
probably familiar
with 32-bit floating point.
As you can see here,
the orange mantissa bits
are all devoted to measuring
these fine differences
between numbers, which is
really important if you're
doing high-performance
computing,
detailed simulations,
that kind of thing.
But in machine
learning, it turns out
that the range is
much more important.
And these machine
learning models
are not super sensitive to these
fine differences by and large.
So the IEEE standard for
a 16-bit floating point
truncates both the
exponent and the mantissa,
as you can see here.
And it really cuts
down the range
of numbers that you can express.
One thing that we're
finding with TensorFlow
is if you're training with
half-precision IEEE like this,
you really have to
pay attention and you
need to get an expert involved
on a model-by-model basis
to make sure that all of your
numbers stay in the right range
and don't overflow.
And those techniques are
difficult to apply in general
across a wide range of models.
With bfloat16, though,
what we've done instead
is saved a lot more bits
for the exponent, which
preserves the range.
And so in many
models, this is a drop
in replacement for float32.
And it's supported seamlessly
by our Cloud TPU hardware.
So those ResNet-50 results that
I was talking about earlier,
those were achieved
with bfloat16.
And as you notice, we're
still achieving that high 76%
top one, or 93%
top five accuracy,
with a minimum of effort
and special casing
on a model-by-model basis.
So here, I'll show
you a brief animation
of the systolic array.
In this slide, it's only 3 by 3,
but imagine this is 128 by 128
to get a sense of
how different this
is from an ordinary
central processing unit,
and how much parallelism there,
which is where we're getting
this fantastic performance.
So here you have
data streaming in.
And what's happening as the
systolic arrays sort of beats
on every step is you're
getting great reuse
of these intermediate
results as the data
is flowing through
the systolic array
and generating the outputs.
So this is super high throughput
for matrix multiplications
and is tightly integrated with
the other parts of our TPU
that support all these
other custom operations.
And our XLA compiler
also does a great job
of taking high-level
mathematical expressions
and then mapping them down
into this coordinated dance
of low-level operations that
gives this tremendous amount
of speed.
So where do we go from here?
Well, first of
all, I really want
to emphasize something I
haven't called out explicitly
about scaling up.
I think the days of single
systems are irrelevant.
They're over because
what you care
about, ultimately, is how fast
you get to your result, right?
And so what we're trying to
do with these Cloud TPUs,
and making them widely
available in the cloud,
is giving you just
a dial that you
can turn where you
do your prototyping
on an inexpensive single device,
and then you increase the batch
size without doing any
other code changes,
and suddenly your training
time is going down
from hours to minutes.
And so I'll show you two real
measurements from our TPU
systems in-house
here to give you
a sense of how that's possible.
First of all, what I'm
demonstrating here,
if you look at
these TPU devices--
so the second generation TPU pod
has 64 of these boards in it--
and you can see linear
scaling of images per second
up and to the right here.
And as you know, remember if
you hear images per second,
it's like, but wait,
what about the accuracy?
You can check our
DAWNBench results.
That 30-minute
result also confirms
that we can still get the high
accuracy with this scale out.
But what you can see is that
our interconnect in this pod
is so fast that you don't have
to struggle the way you would
with mixing and matching
hardware on your own,
whether on premise
or in the cloud.
You can just turn the
dial with no code changes,
and benefit from this super
fast proprietary network.
But there's a more
subtle point here
that's a mathematical issue,
which is until recently, it
hasn't been clear how to take
these machine learning models
and increase the
batch size, which
is how many of
these images you're
processing simultaneously
in each step
while you're training.
There's been a huge
amount of research energy
on this recently.
And there have been a
lot of breakthroughs
where we're now able
to train effectively
on much larger batch
sizes from ever before.
That's great news for scaling
up with these TPU pods.
Let me help you
interpret this graph.
What you see on the
horizontal axis here is time.
And then what you see on the
vertical axis is accuracy.
And so you might imagine
your first implementation
on your Cloud TPU that
you're renting today gets to,
let's say, 76%
accuracy on ResNet-50.
And that takes a
certain amount of time.
That's that orange
curve out there.
But with no code changes, just
by changing the batch size
in the right way with the
models that we've already
open sourced, you
can pull that time
in as you're using larger and
larger sections of the pod
until you get down to these
30-minute results, or possibly
even better.
So we think this is an extremely
promising research direction.
And we're doing our best in all
these reference implementations
to make sure that it's
immediately accessible to you.
So once these pods become more
widely available in the cloud,
then you'll be able to
just transparently benefit
from this large-batch training.
I'd love to live
in a world where
you can use an
exaflop for a minute,
and then let it go
and think for a while,
while somebody else is using it,
and just swap back and forth.
Now, here's another view
of the full TPU v3 pod
that Sundar showed
you this morning.
And we are doing
everything that we
can to push the
boundaries of performance.
And that's what's really led
us to liquid cool this pod,
in comparison to everything
that we've done previously
that's air cooled.
If you want a close-up
view, here it is--
a close-up view of just one
of the boards in that pod.
It looks sort of like this.
And you can see the tubing.
Now, those plates
are on each one
of these next-generation
TPU v3 processors.
So we're going to go to the
largest batch sizes we can.
We're publishing all this
research that we're doing.
We're open sourcing
as much of it
as we can on these
Cloud TPU platforms
that you can access today.
And so we're really
excited in going with you
into this exciting AI frontier.
You can get started right now
with these high-performance
reference models and tutorials.
And please reach out to us.
Let us know.
We'd be really
interested in hearing
your feedback on the Cloud
TPU platform of today.
We'd love to know where
you'd like it to go.
We hope you enjoy trying all
of these different applications
across image recognition, and
speech recognition, and image
generation, and
machine translation.
And I'd be happy to take some
of your questions offline
after the talk.
So thank you very
much for listening.
I've included some links here.
Thanks again.
[MUSIC PLAYING]